good morning John for the project for
awesome last year Travis McElroy and I
did a one-off podcast called the dad
cast a podcast in which two brand new
dads answered questions about being new
dads and the most common question we got
was how do you decide do you make this
tremendous tremendous decision I'm gonna
start this video off by answering the
question you don't know like deciding to
buy three hundred and seventy eight
bottles of Olives if you've never had an
olive just won't know what a terrible
awful poisonous turn fruit they are
until you put one in your mouth or
alternately your child could be the
finest piece of tree flesh you've ever
consumed this metaphor fell apart either
way you have 378 jars of these things
except they're a human being who's never
really opposed or enthusiastic about the
idea of having a kid here's the crazy
thing though after six months I can tell
you that my pros and cons list was raw
here's some stuff that I should have had
on my cons list like the worst parts of
parenthood it's not the puking in the
pooping and the getting up in the middle
of the night and never sleeping a normal
amount again all those things actually
are surprisingly easy sometimes I even
like being excessively kneaded by this
adorable biscuit man but I don't like
one the stress of knowing that my child
could get ill at any moment seriously
we're just generally something terrible
might happen and while you can minimize
risk you cannot eliminate to feeling
like I'm doing it wrong three feeling
like I can't do it at all and when you
have a human being who's depending on
you for everything feeling like you
can't do it as a feeling of tremendous
failure even when it's fleeting even
when you know it's not true I think
everybody experiences this and it's just
one of those it gets better situations
for and this is kind of wrapped up in
all of these caring so much dad it hurts
it was also wrong about the reasons that
I would like having a kid like I knew I
was gonna like having like a little
Catherine Hank hybrid person that's nice
but here are the bigger and unexpected
one one embarking on a really big new
interesting project with my wife who's
my favorite person - I get to sing
wherever I want to as long as he's with
me people will think it's cute and not
we are three I think I have a much
better understanding of my parents
relationship with me which is maybe hard
to have
unless you experience Parenthood
yourself or I have a much better
understanding of and I'm very impressed
by the capabilities of both me and
Kathryn live I really like doing a thing
that is super normal like every lots of
people do this but it's also
magnificently important and I know that
every piece of me unquestionably knows
that being a dad is vitally important
six I love to look at him which I didn't
really expect I love it so much that I
like show him to other people and I'm
like I'm so sorry
that you don't get to stare at this all
the time like I do finally seven caring
so much it hurts again this video
doesn't have any answers it is just the
perspective of one of billions of
parents on earth it is hard I will tell
you that but also the hard things are
the ones that are the most worth doing
and that's not an endorsement of having
a kid it's an endorsement of doing hard
thing you are the only person who can
decide whether you're ready to create a
human but final thing if you are like me
and you assume that all the people who
are talking about how great parenthood
is we're just making it up so that they
would feel less bad about the terrible
decision they made it's not made up it's
actually really great John I'll see you
on Tuesday
endscreen two things first the Ketut
system shirts and stuff will only be
available for another couple days
including we made a laptop decal because
people were talking to the comma spawn
how much they wanted a laptop - you can
- John you and I are gonna be in Seattle
December 9th intent for pod con a
convention for people who love and make
podcast we're doing it in partnership
with the night Vale presents team and
those good good McElroy boys as my
brother my brother and me god calm calm
we're doing a crowdfunding campaign
right now to try and raise more money to
get more cool guests we just announced
that criminal is gonna be there you want
more information pod con comm there's
also a bunch of social medias you can
follow in the description it's gonna be
a good time